The superhero craze is showing no sign of slowing
down anytime soon, and it seems like the next
few years are filled to the brim with comic book
and superhero movies. But what's actually coming
out — and when? Here's everything you need to
know about these upcoming superhero movies.
Sylvester Stallone appeared to retire his
iconic John Rambo character with 2019's Rambo:
Last Blood, but the actor clearly isn't
planning on retiring himself anytime soon.
He'll go from action hero to
superhero in 2021's Samaritan,
a film about a child who discovers the secret
behind a long-forgotten hero's disappearance.
Samaritan is directed by Julius Avery, who
earned praise for helming the WWII zombie
thriller Overlord in 2018. When he was offered the
chance to work with Stallone on his next feature,
he jumped at it. Avery told Deadline:
"Sly is a hero of mine. I'm incredibly
thrilled to be working with such an iconic
actor on this very special project
with Balboa Productions and MGM."
Avery reportedly struck up a great
relationship with Stallone on set,
who called him a "wonderful director" when
the movie wrapped in November 2020 — after
a number of unfortunate coronavirus-related
delays. Stallone shared in an Instagram post:
"Entire crew was tested down to the
last person every day for COVID which
amounted to thousands upon thousands of
tests and we came through like champs."
Samaritan is now due for
release on June 4th, 2021.
After years of teasing, Marvel finally announced
that a standalone Black Widow movie was coming at
Comic-Con 2019. By the end of the year we had our
first teaser for the film, a prequel that takes
place after the events of Captain America: Civil
War. The movie follows Natasha Romanoff as she
goes under the radar and returns to Russia, where
she reunites with her old friends and family.
These new characters include Florence Pugh as
Yelena Belova, Rachel Weisz as Melina Vostokoff,
and David Harbour as Alexi Shostakov, a.k.a.
The Red Guardian. The movie also features
a sinister new villain in Taskmaster, as well
as the return of William Hurt's Thaddeus Ross.
Black Widow has been subject to a whole
heap of controversy and speculation
due to its numerous delays — as well as Disney's
apparent reluctance to release it on Disney+.
Now, though, the movie's status
has finally been confirmed.
Black Widow will hit theaters and Disney+
Premiere Access simultaneously on July 9th, 2021.
One of the highlights of 2020's DC FanDome was
the roll call for James Gunn's The Suicide Squad,
which officially introduced the ensemble cast of
the soft reboot. A number of actors — including
Margot Robbie and Viola Davis — reprise
their roles from 2016's Suicide Squad,
and will be joined by a host of new recruits, to
boot. Gunn is clearly pretty excited about his
anti-hero team-up flick, promising that it'll
be different to anything else he's ever made.
The featurette also revealed that plenty
of big action set-pieces are in store,
with producer Peter Safran describing The Suicide
Squad as kind of like a classic war movie.
"This is a gritty 1970s war movie
combined with the brilliance of
James Gunn's characters and comedy."
A handful of other trailers were released
in early 2021, and they only seem to
further prove what the original featurette
suggested: that this is going to be one crazy
movie. The Suicide Squad will be released in
theaters and on HBO Max on August 6th, 2021.
Above all else, Marvel's self-professed goal
for Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings
is to offer their own perspective on Asian
identity. The studio has hired Asian and
Asian American filmmakers to make sure that
happens, and, judging by the character's history,
that's a pretty smart move. The Hands of
Shang-Chi: Master of Kung Fu comics began as
an unofficial continuation of Bruce Lee's legacy,
and while Marvel's intentions may have been noble,
the execution wasn't always perfect — making
controversial pulp villain Fu Manchu Shang-Chi's
father was undoubtedly a bad move, for example,
and one that's quite rightly been retconned.
The job of bringing Shang-Chi into the modern
age belongs to Chinese American screenwriter
Dave Callaham and Japanese Hawaiian director
Destin Daniel Cretton. The titular role,
meanwhile, has gone to Chinese Canadian actor
Simu Liu. At Comic-Con 2019, Lieu revealed:
"I was cast on Tuesday. I screen-tested on Sunday
in New York. This is the
craziest, craziest dream."
The actor, who is perhaps best known for
the comedy series Fresh Off the Boat,
told a packed Hall H that his parents moved to
North America with next to nothing. He said:
"All I've ever wanted was to make them proud."
Shang-Chi also features Tony Leung as
the villainous Mandarin and Awkwafina
as Shang-Chi’s best friend. The movie
hits theaters on September 3rd, 2021.
In June 2019, Amy Pascal confirmed
that Venom star Tom Hardy would be
reprising the role of Eddie Brock in an
interview with Fandango. The producer said:
"Tom Hardy will be back, magnificently
playing that character as no one else can."
Pascal made no mention of Venom
director Ruben Fleischer, however.
As it turned out, Fleishcer would not be
returning. Instead, Hardy later confirmed
that actor and director Andy Serkis would
be taking the reins for the Venom sequel.
Serkis made his directorial debut in 2017
with heartwarming drama Breathe and proved
his blockbuster chops the following
year with Mowgli: Legend of the Jungle.
Venom's mid-credits scene made it pretty
clear that Sony was plotting a sequel.
It follows Brock as he visits Woody
Harrelson's Cletus Kasady in prison.
"When I get outta here, and I
will, there's gonna be carnage."
Just what form will that carnage take?
You can probably guess — but if you want
to know for sure, you'll need to see Venom:
Let There Be Carnage. The movie arrives
in theaters on September 24th, 2021.
Due to the coronavirus pandemic, Marvel's
Eternals has been bumped to the end of 2021.
Luckily, fans have already been given a few
hints and teasers about the barrier-breaking
cosmic blockbuster. The film will apparently take
place over a period of 7,000 years, according to
Kevin Feige, and will follow the exploits of
the eponymous immortals known as the Eternals.
The impressive ensemble cast
includes Angelina Jolie as Thena,
Richard Madden as Ikaris, and Kit Harington
as the Black Knight, Dane Whitman.
Meanwhile, Gemma Chan will
appear as the human-loving Sersi,
Kumail Nanjiani is playing Kingo, Lauren Ridloff
is Makkari, Brian Tyree Henry is Phastos,
Lia McHugh is Sprite, Don Lee is
Gilgamesh, Barry Keoghan is Druig,
and Salma Hayek is Ajak, "leader" of the group.
Sound like a lot? That's comic books,for you.
MCU overlord Kevin Feige has also
confirmed that Eternals will feature
the MCU's first openly gay characters. Actor
Haaz Sleiman later told Entertainment Weekly:
"I'm married to the gay superhero Phastos,
played by Atlanta's Brian Tyree Henry,
and we represent a gay family and have a child."
Marvel's first deaf superhero, Makkari, will also
debut, making this the most representative MCU
movie to date. According to a leaked tie-in
toy, the villain of the picture will be Kro,
a powerful member of the hideous
species known as the Deviants.
Nomadland director and Oscar frontrunner
Chloe Zhao directs from a script by Matthew
and Ryan Firpo. Eternals will be
released on November 5th, 2021.
Over the last few months, news on the upcoming
Spider-Man has continued to trickle through.
Some of the most tantalizing tidbits about
the movie, titled Spider-Man: No Way Home,
include the fact that Jamie Foxx and
Alfred Molina are both returning to
Marvel as Electro and Doctor Octopus
respectively. In October 2020,
The Hollywood Reporter's sources revealed that
Foxx's character from the Andrew Garfield movies
was set for a shock return in October 2020, and
a few months later they revealed that Molina,
who went toe-to-toe with Toby Maguire's
Spidey, is also going to feature in the movie.
"Where do all these guys come from?"
Foxx himself later hinted at Garfield
and Maguire reprising their roles in a
hastily-deleted Instagram post, and there's been
talk of Emma Stone and Kirsten Dunst coming back,
too. Three generations of Spider-Man
movies could allegedly collide in
this highly anticipated threequel…
but how is this actually possible?
Well, Sony has been embracing the idea
of a shared multiverse with its animated
Spider-Verse franchise, and we know the concept
will play a big part in upcoming MCU projects,
most notably culminating with Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness. Fittingly, Benedict
Cumberbatch's Stephen Strange will reportedly play
a supporting role in Holland's third solo film,
taking over as Peter Parker's mentor. The movie
swings into theaters on December 17th, 2021.
Sony dropped the first trailer
for Morbius in January 2020,
and it was met with a mixture of confusion and
excitement. The three-minute clip was essentially
a mini-origin story for lesser-known
Marvel antihero Dr. Michael Morbius,
a brilliant scientist who turns to vampirism
after his attempts to cure his rare blood
disease have mixed results. Morbius debuted
as an enemy of Peter Parker in 1971's
Amazing Spider-Man #101, but became more
of a sympathetic figure in later issues.
While this movie is very much part of Sony's
own universe of Marvel characters, the Morbius
teaser contained a few easter eggs that raised
questions about the film's relationship to the
MCU. For example, the word "murderer" has been
graffitied across an image of Spidey in one scene,
indicating that this is Tom
Holland's version of the character,
who was framed by Mysterio
in Spider-Man: Far From Home.
If that wasn't enough, Michael Keaton shows up
as Adrian Toomes, confirming that Morbius is
tied to the MCU in some way or another.
As such, some fans are predicting that
Morbius might sow the seeds for a big screen
Sinister Six — but just what form that movie
might take in Sony's universe has yet to be seen.
Morbius will be released on January 21st, 2022.
The first trailer for Robert Pattinson's
upcoming Batman movie dropped during DC FanDome,
revealing plot details, first looks at villains,
and the darkest big screen version of the Caped
Crusader yet. Pattinson's stripped-down Batsuit
is on full display in the trailer, including
a particularly shocking scene in which he
straight-up lays into an unfortunate gang member.
"I'm vengeance."
What's immediately clear from the footage is
that The Batman will be unlike any Bat-film
that's come before it, and not just
in terms of grit and violence — since
writer-director Matt Reeves is going
back to the Dark Knight's early days.
During the FanDome panel, Reeves revealed that
Pattinson's Bruce Wayne is in "Year 2" of his
Batman career, referencing the famous late
'80s arc of the same name. The first trailer
also offered up a glimpse of Zoë Kravitz
as Catwoman and Colin Farrell's Penguin,
but it's also clear that Paul Dano's
Riddler will be the movie's main threat.
Having been delayed a number of times
due to the coronavirus pandemic,
The Batman will now arrive in
theaters on March 4th, 2022.
When Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness was announced at Comic-Con 2019,
returning director Scott Derrickson claimed
it would be the first properly scary MCU film.
Kevin Feige, however, was quick to downplay the
idea. Then, during an appearance at the New York
Film Academy, Marvel's president said that he
"wouldn't necessarily" call it a horror in the
traditional sense. Derrickson exited the project
over creative differences a few weeks later.
Marvel wasted no time in finding a replacement,
and their apparent choice has gone down pretty
well with fans. Veteran horror director
Sam Raimi began talking to the studio
about the project in February 2020, and was soon
brought on to the project properly. Derrickson,
for his part, called Raimi's hiring
a "great choice" on Marvel's part.
Raimi, whose Spider-Man movies laid the
foundation for the modern superhero film,
remains a fan favorite director in the
comic book world, and will likely bring
some prestige to Benedict Cumberbatch's second
solo outing as Stephen Strange. They'll be
working from a script by Michael Waldron, the
head writer of upcoming Disney+ series, Loki.
A couple of new MCU characters will
make their debuts in the movie,
with some sources suggesting that the story will
introduce the iconic Marvel characters Clea and
Brother Voodoo. But you can expect plenty of
familiar faces to appear, too. Elizabeth Olsen's
Scarlet Witch is going to feature prominently in
the movie, while Chiwetel Ejiofor, Benedict Wong,
and Rachel McAdams are also expected to
return. The madness begins on March 25th, 2022.
News that Chris Hemsworth and Taika Waititi
were teaming up for another Thor movie broke
days before Comic-Con 2019, but the biggest
announcement came at the event itself — that
Natalie Portman is returning to the franchise.
The Oscar winner portrayed Thor's earthbound
love interest Jane Foster in 2011's Thor
and 2013's Thor: The Dark World,
but was absent for 2017's Thor:
Ragnarok, with an explanation briefly
given that the pair had broken up.
"She didn't dump me, you know. I
dumped her. It was a mutual dumping."
After that, Portman appeared to
be done with Marvel — but her
character in the Marvel comics has developed
significantly since her last film appearance.
Most notably, in a 2014 story, Foster
was deemed worthy to wield Thor's hammer,
and adopted the title Goddess of Thunder. We
don't know how this will all play out on screen,
but Waititi clearly has big plans
for both Portman and Jane Foster.
Aside from that, the director has
been tight-lipped on plot details,
but he at least dropped a few tantalizing teases
during an April 2020 watch party for Thor:
Ragnarok. Waititi revealed that he intends to
introduce starsharks to the MCU, for example,
and also left the door open
for a possible Loki return.
"Surprise."
It's also been confirmed that the movie's main
villain, Gorr the God Butcher, will be played by
MCU debutant Christian Bale. Meanwhile, Tessa
Thompson will be back in action as Valkyrie,
and the Guardians of the Galaxy
are also set to make an appearance.
Perhaps strangest of all, however, is the news
that the Asgardian actors from Ragnarok are also
returning for the movie. This time around,
Luke Hemsworth, Matt Damon and Sam Neill
are joined by Melissa McCarthy, who
is playing the stage version of Hela.
Wanna know what that's all about? Find out when
Love and Thunder is released on May 6th, 2022.
The planned sequel to the smash hit
Black Panther suffered a massive blow
in August 2020 with the heartbreaking
and untimely loss of Chadwick Boseman.
The actor was diagnosed with colon cancer in
2016, the year he made the first of his four
appearances as the African superhero. For
a number of reasons, Boseman chose to keep
his diagnosis private — even from Marvel and
filmmaker Ryan Coogler. Coogler later said:
"I spent the last year preparing,
imagining and writing words for him to say,
that we weren't destined to see. It leaves me
broken knowing that I won't be able to watch
another close-up of him in the monitor again
or walk up to him and ask for another take."
Boseman's death was reportedly
devastating for everyone at Disney,
but conversations about where the franchise
should go have now begun behind the scenes.
Marvel has made it clear they have
no intention of recasting the role,
so that means the Black Panther mantle
is likely to be handed over to a new
character earlier than expected — something
there's actually a well-known precedent for.
In the comics, T'Challa's younger
half-sister Shuri has her Black Panther
training fast-tracked after he is severely
injured by villains loyal to Namor — who,
as it happens, has been rumored to appear as
the sequel's big bad. But whether it's Shuri,
another of T'Challa's allies, or a brand new
character altogether, whoever takes on the mantle
of Black Panther will have some very big shoes
to fill. We'll see how they do on July 8th, 2022.
Dwayne Johnson has been touting a Black Adam
movie for well over a decade. He became officially
attached to play the character in 2014, and was
originally supposed to debut as Adam in Shazam!.
But in 2017, execs decided the character was too
big for a supporting role, and needed his own solo
movie instead. News has been painfully slow since
then, but things picked up a little during DC's
FanDome event in summer 2020. There wasn't any
actual footage to show, but Johnson nevertheless
debuted a brief teaser made up of stills created
by DC's Jim Lee and Instagram artist BossLogic.
Johnson narrates the teaser in character,
explaining that he was imprisoned some 5,000 years
earlier when his home, the fictional nation of
Kahndaq, was a "melting pot of magic and powers."
In the comics, Adam is a vengeful slave who's
granted the gifts of the wizard Shazam and
uses them for good — before eventually being led
astray. Johnson confirmed that the Justice Society
of America will feature in the film, and we now
know who's playing them. Aldis Hodge is Hawkman,
Noah Centineo is Atom Smasher, Quintessa
Swindell is Cyclone, and — rounding out
the main cast with his superhero movie debut –
Pierce Brosnan is Dr. Fate. Rising star Bodhi
Sabongui will also reportedly be showing
up as a "key" yet "secret" character.
Jaume Collet-Serra, who directed Johnson in
Disney's Jungle Cruise, is working from a
script by Adam Sztykiel, who wrote the former
wrestler's 2018 actioner, Rampage. Filming on
Black Adam began in April 2021, with the movie
itself set for a July 29th, 2022 release date.
The sequel to 2018's Spider-Man: Into the
Spider-Verse was already in the works by the time
the original movie hit theaters. Given how long
the first movie took to complete, however, that's
not at all surprising. Into the Spider-Verse was
four years in the making — which made fans all
the more worried about potential delays to the
project when the coronavirus pandemic struck.
Thankfully, the movie's schedule doesn't seem
to have been affected, and lead animator Nick
Kondo confirmed that production had
officially begun in a June 2020 tweet.
The second of the original
movie's post-credits scenes
gave fans a major clue about
where the story could be headed,
introducing viewers to Miguel O'Hara, a.k.a.
Spider-Man 2099. This future version of Spidey,
voiced by Oscar Isaac, is given a watch that
allows him to travel between dimensions.
"This could literally not get any weirder."
Reportedly, the sequel is also set
to feature Japanese Spider-Man,
while Spider-Man: The Animated Series star
Christopher Daniel Barnes has revealed that
he would love to play his version of Spider-Man
in the movie. He told Recording Time Media:
"If I could do that again, I'd be honored."
Into the Spider-Verse 2 is due
for release on October 7th, 2022.
Ezra Miller's long-awaited solo outing as
Barry Allen was thrown into peril in 2020,
when a clip of him appearing to choke a female fan
went viral. Nonetheless, Warner Bros. decided to
stick by the actor actor, and right now The Flash
remains very much in the pipeline. The project was
actually given the name Flashpoint back in 2017
— which is also the name of an epic DC event,
one which saw the Flash turn the whole universe
on its head by traveling backwards in time to save
his mother. We don't know how closely director
Andy Muschietti and writer Christina Hodson's film
will follow the well-known and beloved arc, but
we do at least know who's going to be in it.
Barry Allen's mom will be played by Maribel
Verdú, while Ron Livingston will portray his dad,
having taken over the role from a double-booked
Billy Crudup. According to Variety, Saoirse-Monica
Jackson and YouTube star Rudy Mancuso will also
feature. In bigger news, it's been confirmed that
Sasha Calle has been cast as Supergirl and will be
making her debut alongside the Scarlet Speedster.
Plus, Ben Affleck will be returning as
Batman, with Muschietti telling Vanity Fair
that Affleck is "a very substantial part
of the emotional impact of the movie."
Muschietti has also said that Michael
Keaton's 1989 Batman would appear in the film,
playing a "substantial" part in Barry Allen's
tale. However, in March 2021, Keaton himself
told Deadline that he was unsure whether or not
he would take up the cowl again. As he explained:
"I am needing a minute to think about
it because I'm so fortunate and blessed,
I got so much going on now. I'm
really into work right now."
With Keaton or without him, The Flash is
scheduled for release on November 4th, 2022.
Kevin Feige gave away nothing about Captain Marvel
2 when he revealed his MCU Phase 4 plans back in
2019, but we now know a whole lot more about the
upcoming sequel. Brie Larson will reprise the
role of Carol Danvers, and she will be facing
off against Velvet Buzzsaw actor Zawe Ashton,
who, according to Deadline, has been cast as a
thus-far unidentified villain. The same outlet
has revealed that Teyonah Parris' Monica Rambeau
will feature, reprising her WandaVision role,
as will Iman Vellani's Kamala Khan, focus
of the upcoming Disney+ series Ms. Marvel.
The coronavirus pandemic inevitably slowed
the movie down a little, but production on
Captain Marvel 2 reportedly began in earnest
in early January 2021. That same month,
Larson spoke to Lilly Singh about
the hiring of director Nia DaCosta,
who is set to become the first Black
woman to direct an MCU movie. She said:
"It's amazing, and I'm so excited that
it's announced and I can talk about it.
Nia is amazing and she got the job
because she is the best person for
the job. She just gave an incredible
presentation and I'm inspired by her."
Captain Marvel 2 will be
released on November 11th, 2022.
A sequel to 2018's Aquaman seemed
inevitable from the moment James Wan's
underwater epic dethroned The Dark Knight
Rises as the highest grossing DC movie ever.
In January 2019, Deadline revealed that Warner
Bros. wanted Wan to oversee development of
Aquaman 2 and had given the director
permission to select his own writer.
A few weeks later, The Hollywood Reporter
confirmed that David Leslie Johnson-McGoldrick,
who co-wrote the original movie, had been
hired for the sequel. And while Aquaman 2
will be very much their brainchild, it
seems that Jason Momoa has been chipping
in with some ideas, too. In October
2019, he told Entertainment Tonight:
"[I] went into Warner Bros in D.C. and said,
'You know, I have some ideas.' They love them,
and James [Wan] and everyone is like, 'We're all
taking it in. We're excited to do another one.'"
The actor wouldn't get into specifics,
but he promised that Aquaman 2 was going to be
"way bigger" than the first installment, saying:
"There's a lot more in store on so many
more levels. There's going to be a lot."
All we know for sure about the plot of the
sequel is that the titular hero will face
off against classic nemesis Black Manta, who
was rescued by an obsessive scientist in the
first movie's mid-credits scene. Aquaman
2 hits theaters on December 16th, 2022.
Released in 2019, Shazam! was a major win
for Warner Bros., with the vast majority of
critics praising the film's departure from
the somber tone that had come to define DC
movies. There's nothing official on the
upcoming sequel in terms of plot yet,
but we do know that director David F. Sandberg
and screenwriter Henry Gayden are both back,
and all the principal cast members
are expected to return, too.
But who will the Shazamily be
up against this time out? Well,
one of the Shazam! post-credit tags introduced
a talking caterpillar-like creature that fans of
the comics will surely have recognized as Mister
Mind, a traditional adversary of Billy Batson.
"Oh, what fun we're going to have together.
The seven realms are about to be ours."
It's also been confirmed that Helen Mirren and
Lucy Liu will play villains by the name of Hespera
and Kalypso, respectively. They're
both sisters, original characters,
and daughters of the god Atlas, whose most
popular run in the comics came under Jack
Kirby's stewardship in the mid-'70s. Shazam: Fury
of the Gods will be released on June 2nd, 2023.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.